one of the most unique entertainment
venues in the world is one step closer
to completion today crews held a topping
off ceremony for the msg sphere near the
venetian and palazzo our very own joe
mueller got a tour and he is live this
afternoon near the attraction with a
look and of course the big question when
is it expected to open joe
christian and kirsten as both of you
know we have watched crews put together
the msgc for over a year now
now the steel structure on the outside
is complete and soon he'll be wrapped in
monitors well today my photojournalist
mark zamora and i got a look inside of
las vegas next big venue
the msg sphere will change the live
entertainment experience tuesday crews
put up the last beams on top of the
outside of the world's largest spherical
structure it will also be covered with
the world's largest monitor inside there
will be seventeen thousand five hundred
seats surrounded by even more monitors
to create an immersive experience nick
tomasino is msg entertainment senior
vice president of construction up and
around us
is the structural steel that all the led
will attach to the steel is about four
acres that's almost three football
fields in size that all the led will
make up the spear is estimated to cost
around 1.8 billion dollars the venue
will be capable of hosting attractions
artists residencies as well as corporate
events
come july crews will start putting the
monitors on the outside of the structure
now that process for that will take
about 10 to 12 months as for when this
could all be finished they expect it to
be done by the second half of 2023
reporting live near the strip john
muller live local now